concernant les techniques de
modification génétique des plantes et
des cultures la pratique du secret
dénoncée hier par deux organisations
écologistes fait partie des
préoccupations de la ministre Dominique
voanet mais il y a forte à faire ainsi
dans l'exemple rapporté par François
Privat et Philippe Riten nous sommes
dans la commune de Chambon près de La
Rochelle en Charente Maritime au début
de l'été dernier des paysans font
alliance avec des écologistes contre la
culture d'une céréale mutante mais la
suite de l'enquête que viennent
d'effectuer nos reporterurs révèle des
cont adiction
réglementaire en juin dernier le coup de
force d'agriculteur de la Confédération
paysane contre une parcelle de cols
transgénique une expérimentation menée
sur 4 hectares à Chambon en charante
maritime dans la plus grande discrétion
en France conformément et Noi de 1992
toute expérimentation sur des plantes
transgéniques doit être déclarée à la
mairie de la commune ici des
agriculteurs accompagné d'un Nuissier
n'ont rien trouvé aucune trace de cette
parcelle de colza parcelle de colza que
jeis visiter au auparavant avec un
agriculteur qui nous avait convié à
venir voir inquiet qu'il était quoi
parce que lui-même était venu à la
mairie pour voir s'il y avait s'il y
avait quelque chose rien pas de trace
parcel fantôme 8 mois plus tard le champ
de colsa transgénique est devenu champ
de blé et des questions subsistent
notamment à propos d'une liste dressée
en décembre
1997 par la Direction Départementale de
l'Agriculture à La Rochelle alors que le
cols transgénique est déjà semé nous
dénonçons effectivement une opacité
administrative évidente qui aboutit
à au fait que l'on découvre par hasard
le fait qu'un champ a été planté en OGM
sans aucune concertation sans aucune
information en tous les cas le directeur
de la DDA de Charente Maritime n'a pas
souhaité nous recevoir il affirme
cependant avoir rajouté ce champ de cols
à cette liste sans nous en fournir la
preuve l'expérience de Chambon était
menée par le setium le centre technique
des oléagineux métropolitains ses
responsables affirment avoir mené cette
expérience en s'abritant derrière une
réglementation européenne de
1996 effectivement c'est assez ambigu il
y a ces deux types de réglementation et
nous on s'était confronté enfin on avait
pris référence sur la réglementation
européenne sur ce type d'expérimentation
par souci de discrétion non pas par
souci de discrétion parce que ça on éé
sur ces textes européens quelques
ambiguités entre législation européenne
et française qui sur le cols
transgénique ne favorise pas la
transparence en matière
d'information